well how long will we be in the studio
do you think seven years no really seven
years of studio have you seen that movie
no it sounds nice though yeah it's about
two guys you get stuck in a studio for
seven miles he's got a podcast for seven
years on a plantation and there's a guy
in the back is like whipping them
Podcast boys
it's Brandon let's start this thing do
we start
is it is it Chinese New Year why Chinese
no I'm not either are you know what are
we talking about why are we so much
Chinese dude but it is their new year
yeah it always is you know yeah it's the
year that I I feel like every year
is it not year the dog count what is it
okay yeah ah I don't like swine myself
really not like pork I'm like pork chops
you don't like mouse that has pork in it
bacon pork sandwiches pork chops pork
ribs I'm just going through the list
about ribs yeah they have pork ribs pork
ribs are broken whose though but who
would eat a rib off a pig dude you've
seen a pig huh they're cutest yeah dude
some of them are cute some of them are
very very uh disgruntled he's not my
warthog then no I'm talking about look
at come on bro you're gonna eat his face
off you know people eat their snouts
otherwise in the back I don't eat the
front yeah don't want eat the [ __ ]
don't even sell that I don't think you
can get it on the dark web I think or
maybe a CVS in the back notice the
reason why the pigs of the Chinese
animals yeah that's not a front door
item you can't go into a damn CVS and
get a PAP soy sauce whatever you want
all over the high oh dude you got to put
a condiment if you eat pig [ __ ]
straight you take a hairline flu man
what's going on not too much man I hurt
my I've heard a muscle in my arm doing
what nothing
yeah walking into a meeting I think I
rolled over really hard in my sleep do
you roll her a new teddy bear do you
sleep with Teddy rough skin oh dude that
thing was hard as [ __ ] out of Teddy
Ruxpin
yeah it's Ruxpin you remember those how
hard they were that batteries hit him
bro battery they dude a bandbox teddy
bear surrounded by a boombox was like
yeah I had one as a kid and his jaw fell
off and him scariest [ __ ] bro do you
remember the big loss between Teddy
Ruxpin and the Shoney's bear let's pull
up that Shoney's bear is what was the
Shoni bit of the Holly cab
well it was they had a real legal issue
over that it was the same bear ah the
same bear for you look I can Sugar
Smacks look take away the overalls take
away that Shoney's red smock that he has
I mean they're both bears that's about
it well look past the outfit and see if
it's not the same bear can we do a
side-by-side with that Shoney's bear
does that one talk and that Teddy Ruxpin
oh yeah no I have the original dick I
wore payless shoes and withdraw Nike
signs on in the Tony rub skins dude I
had them airflight 9010 a fleet you know
always had like it was um it was like a
swimmer I had their shoes or some I had
like those look at the Aqua socks
yeah like car like I had those Michael
spits you're like Jesus they have shoes
for this don't shoot let's see look at
these bears and they had the lawsuit and
no one tell you Ruskin's
dude daddy get over it man dude Teddy
Ruskin sounds like a black dude can we
pull up really I don't if you can put
that there no ten rubs give you some
weird [ __ ] yeah Teddy Ruskin sounds like
a straight brother this definitely
sounds like a brother back in the day
like old-school it sound like a mice
have a vice-principal named Rowley
Coleman and he's just sleeping a trunk
of his car over there Duras during
recess at the school it sounds like a
security guard I had an open house Teddy
roughs cos you don't mr. rubb don't
[ __ ] this ruff skits teddy Ruskin
sounds like the first black Native
American nude oh you know one bro you
know I'm talking about big dog over
there that matter River Teddy Ruxpin oh
boy that's good all cuz I can't leave
yet bootleg hey man sometimes sometimes
the budget didn't include my toys
respect man yeah you know how it goes do
one time my mom for Christmas she got us
a bunch of two-liter sodas and we just
shook him up and sprayed him all over
each other that's a good time knew we
had a blast my mom just got us the whiz
Cheez Whiz so she's like do what you
want
Phil each other up yeah
he's our silly-string I need it and then
also pretty good yeah smart we think
about it that's not a vanity bias cleats
and we just wear them till they became
regular shoes yeah the molded cleats Wow
yes twice as long you guys went through
a lot yeah man
Wow a lot well Teddy Ruxpin is it man
let's get into let's let's start this up
also here's the other thing from now on
the podcast will be available every
Thursday morning yeah like last week so
much and when fans appreciate it where
the podcasts will drop every Thursday
morning yeah and this is a wonderful way
for you to get in touch with yourself on
a Thursday and the week right bra yeah
in the week right did a lot of people at
the end of the week they don't know what
they're doing they're driving around the
park you know their kids are asleep
they're smoking drugs are waiting for
happy hour
yeah dude they're [ __ ] you know can
breathe for Google and Teddy ruff ruff
skins on the internet they don't you
know they've lost their way by and see
babies yeah but you monkeys yes yeah
buying stuff off the dark web but this
is a chance for you to finish a week
strong and that's what it'll be that's
what we're doing with it it was like Oh
Monday Tuesday er I come we're like now
we're coming up the back door coming up
that poop chute Thursday well also we're
just releasing the thing on Thursdays
we're not doing anything just sit but we
also want to thank our we have a new
writer that's helping us out just by
putting us some [ __ ] to get that Black
Lung huh yeah we also want to thank we
got a new associate let's open it out
our boy Derek post and he's a comedian
and he's helping us just find some good
stuff to scour the web and he's a real
artful guy and he hosts or guy at the
Comedy Store
yeah and I'll be honest he's diverse
that's how we roll give it up boom
that's it brother [ __ ] touch barely
how we were hole dude what do you mean
white guys dude are we I'm polish
Nicaraguan so whatever I don't know what
I am I did 2013 it still hasn't come
through that was a year ago okay they're
just trying to figure it out oh right go
with everyone well you sent him that
really how much do you put in there I
pissed in the whole bottle filled it all
the way up oh wow they think everyone
else did it but we're still waiting
oh you give him a lot more dude I give
him a lot more than asked for they asked
for that little line I throw in a little
court yeah I'll give them all they can
I want you have more than less yeah oh I
do in a bottle of Code Red in there I
poured a little bit of that in yeah I'll
throw a little fresca and then just to
mix it up I see how good they are
oh dude throw a little milk and there
you [ __ ] mi fresca and my human you
think you're the reason I paid $99 all
right what do we got how this drug was a
red mud drip but actually I got one I
want to throw in under the belt here
you mean below the belt shout out the
show time yeah and also shout out to the
fact that I will be at the Houston
improv asleep oh wow and Thursday night
we still need some people to come out
we got a Thursday Late Show and next
weekend I'll be in Boston in two
weekends from now in Medford at the
Chevallier theater Boston fantastic yeah
I'll be in Miami March 15th and 16 are
you nervous about that I'd be nervous
about Miami yeah why they I look like I
could fit in are you a little more Brown
one more tan I'm like oh he's one of us
you gotta get tits though in an ass yeah
yeah you're never gonna yeah we'll
figure out either way I met Miami improv
and then after I met the DC improv get
to get fun spots yep wherever you going
with this though well I was going with
this before beginning to rip my drift
dude I want to say joke my smoke I was
looking on the internet the other day
and Brennan showers came up with your
boy [ __ ] na Elan muscadine somebody
put a side-by-side you guys smoking out
[ __ ] happy the devil's lettuce
smoking that happy grass so mr. Joseph
Rogan and his we just don't come from
your local distributor I don't know
where he goes it comes out it's gold and
I'll show my yes [ __ ] probably grows
that [ __ ] some Troy Diaz my smuggle in
his ass tremendous tremendous [ __ ]
I don't know how he does it but that
weed is so strong yeah well first of all
it's hella strong when you poke it like
Salvador Dali like I got like a
gentleman like this bro look oh yeah
puff puff give puff puff give to my
friends puff puff give yourself give
yourself up my kids smoking that rope
I'm in that wrote I'm gonna call arrows
I'm about to exterminate you as you look
broke first of all can you look like
like a side piece for ms-13 that's what
we look like in this rope you look like
the dude that's ms-13 pays to bang out
look I got a little Halloween facial
hair
Salvador Dali don't actually smoke mr.
Dean side piece dude it was like a
Patrick Swayze Halloween collapsible
whatever whatever dude
look how you smoke weber did you even
get I didn't or you get diarrhea
I inhaled that bro Ilan did it really he
long was too scared
oh brain cell so I proved that not me
dude Ilan just that dirty he's just a
he's a dirty Ford dealer brought what I
think dude he's just selling these
[ __ ] little air Ford's that's what I
think so my dad's with wheels Donnell
[ __ ] oh you need a subway brilliant you
invented a subway go to New York yeah oh
look at this it's flying through the air
yeah it's a [ __ ] plane [ __ ] God
let's see em bro you gotta let me smoke
no like you need to call Teddy rough
skin and have it Oh Teddy that's not
right now
that's the Teddy rough skin [ __ ]
tendency there that's that and then look
I hand it in to you like you can't even
be around weed or drink so I just start
itching it okay hun your mouth gets real
dry but you can blow it on my face
brother this won't tell my sponsor
here's what I'm saying duties if you if
you ever seen yourself smoke weed bro
you'll learn a lot about yourself and
you smoke it like you're at like a fine
wine
oh yeah like you're at a nice place dude
like you're at a damn [ __ ] double
tree or something you know you got to
get your life together man look at that
you smoked it like you
waiting for people to come downstairs
and talk to you about some yeah look let
me give Elon Musk all confidence well
that thing up as you know as he lost his
job doing that and literally you know
actually promoted show time getting a
promotion after they saw that it's
fantastic That's not me an Elan but that
is uh that's called joke my smoke and
see if you have a buddy who knows who's
smoking dope and he does it a really
weird way by an awesome wait folks do it
like me dude that's Teddy rough skin bro
I think cuz you can pass it to your
friends easier that's why I do that
oh then here try like this look at this
no what the [ __ ] is this
there's an [ __ ] no that's what you do
it bro you don't bro non Venice Beach
really oh that's it just seems weird man
alright let's move on you have one if
you got a friend who's smoking he's he
don't know how to smoke it right or he
smokes it wrong or he does something
different or if he smokes are like me
send that [ __ ] in yeah send it in that
joke my smoke man and will rip him up
for you
gang bro let's get into some rip [ __ ]
ribs mmm alright how the first one for
rip my drip it's Chloe le well goddamn
Chloe whoa I mean is there some
background on this where we at with this
yeah from Dallas Texas
is that real hi Molly the kid the candy
hot tamale bro a redhead bro this is
look more like rape my drape bro it
sounds like you cannot if you walk
around dressed like this with your legs
open oh that's not safe no that's a cat
call in the trailer park yeah this is
more like uh you know smash my patch I
feel like this is not gonna end well no
this is not gonna well this I get kid
it's exactly kidnap in some parts of
America yeah how old is she did we
clarify that she's over 18 oh this is
how you go hitchhiking in Jamaica right
here this is a Jamaican hitchhiker did
when you just open your legs up like
that that's really you guys sure the
wrong part of town you get you out to
get DP'd by a couple friends leave a
couple of Ruxpin huh
couple ruffians gonna fit both their
things in you did it look like yeah she
might meet uh but someone Jesse just his
smallest boys out there smallest boys
gonna see those camo pants from a mile
away
use that noose that's that crammed of
flaws bro she trying to get crammed up
because that trailer park but also she
seems like somebody who just you know
she obviously does yoga and she
oh that's trailer park yoga oh dude I've
seen this trailer park Yoga the middle
the trailer park you just [ __ ]
stretch that's Khloe le huh wow she
looks nice though she looks like a fun
time I should say that she looks like a
fun time I'll tell you this if there was
like 70 people hitchhiking with their
thumbs out and she used this method her
open up that door and have a rock-hard
boner dude you can actually just have
your boner open the door I bet you wish
yeah and she's game but I just flies in
yeah she obviously does a lot of um
pretty eyes too oh come on don't be that
guy I thought we're trying to be
positive yeah we are it's a little late
oh there we go
oh wow she does have nice eyes dude
don't jump into the Nightside train now
oh geez that uh and what was she what
did she wanted she won't rip my dress my
dress
what did she want she must be look at
the sun shining on her camo joggers you
know what dude I mean I can't fake it
man I can't say that she's trying like
if somebody's holding their crotch wide
open like this there's something you
know don't come out we were the me to
movement if you're gonna pick take
pictures like this yeah dude if you're
throwing meat too you know I'm saying
she's dropping you know she's showing
that [ __ ] ham salad out here
Betty blue balls over here yeah I mean
definitely and where is she she's
sitting on a dirty street hmm that's
true bro ain't a trailer park yeah
there's kind of palm fronds and benches
mmm you know what she might be at the
farmers market trying to get the last
tangerine bro last few strawberries I
feel like I'm about to play uh what's
that game this game you born no oh
Badman no tennis no
tabletop ping-pong yeah bro yeah I mean
where did you learn to play did you play
ping pong with chopsticks low ceilings
we had very low ceiling okay like four
foot um I actually have a Stockholm
Syndrome is what I had but I'll say this
though if you're gonna wear these types
of pants you got a camouflage better if
you're trying to not act like you're
showing your cross to people because
this is you know I'm saying this is that
they call that uh they definitely call
this so that's that bunnyranch
hitchhiker what she's doing right now
and this is going to get picked up in
Vegas do this how you hitchhike in Vegas
it's a good way to hitchhike convey it's
also a good way to get paid by them
truckers you could easily turn out be a
lot lizard yeah she might be a lot
lizard yeah she might be a trailer-park
rat oh and I'd be damned Jake the snake
Roberts boy call me a pet store owner
she seems like a very nice lady seems
educated you can tell she has a nice
jacket looks like she may be wore that
Jack has a friendly face friendly face
maybe a body double of the game of
Thrones queen she seems like Laura Croft
womb Raider no ha ha yeah Laura crotch
womb Raider let's move on yeah let's
move on young lady what's up close you
know she's okay wherever she is she's
still alive I hope she's getting paid
for whatever she's doing right now oh
damn damn and this is the kind of baby
that happens if when you have those
pants on and you have a child dude mr.
swaggy swaggy tropical style looks like
a tropical [ __ ] snow cone yeah yeah
this dude seems like weekend at Bernie
Madoff spur oh if Bernie Madoff was a
gay fella selling highlighters this guy
seemed like a good guy where's he from
it doesn't say where she looks like like
you let my three-year-old drawls outfit
well he looks like a smurf at a rave you
know let me think a smurf on ecstasy
yeah he looks like a nice guy I'm not
the yellow pollen I can't tell
is he Polynesia yes very much so look at
the as the peace sign can't tell what is
it lies the place behind them chin zoom
in on that lies plates i watch way too
much first 48 that's Australia or New
Zealand is it Wales brother that's like
that out there bro oh you can wear
whatever you want out there
I don't have to wear clothes well also
the fact that he decided to do this we
should approve and they got very
dangerous animals out there if you ever
some bro nine out of ten people you know
from Australia been bit by something
that's how they circumcised our kids
Oh Dan I was get on that dick just put a
little love flavouring on that on that
[ __ ] wiener me and then a tiger will
just come snack it off boy you know that
guy looks like something a grand old
time though always seems like a nice guy
looks like he's about to jump on us is
that a Harley what is that the bumper is
that a motorcycle that might be a
question
it's a wheelchair first of all G right
oh you jumped out of the wheelchair yeah
dude it's Oscar you can do whatever you
want bro hey being handicapped in
Australia is so much easier than being
handicapped in the US is that how the
bouncers look at their clubs there maybe
if the club is staples okay this dude's
Eve I keep trying to keep even clubs
Hobby Lobby after this dude though what
else we got what's-his-name Navarone now
so obviously he's a Native American
he's a native non-american he's lives in
another country native Australian native
Zealand he's an Aboriginal mm-hmm and if
he's an Aboriginal man they walk they
were all kind of stuff you know they
were all moved out there oh you'll see
an Aboriginal wearing a you know a hat
made out of their grandfather they do
all kind of wild [ __ ] like that
his name's Navarone Davis and this next
one is Brennan AKB fug it was submitted
by his cousin Danielle [ __ ] yeah be thug
god damn be thug Oh what do we got here
he's fresh off the lot
fresh off the yard Oh fresh off the yard
he looks like the missing member of Big
Pun in the terrace cry yeah he looks
like Fat Joe's priest he looks like Fat
Joe Joe's driver he looks like a
lifeguard at a baptism in uh in rural
Georgia he'd definitely have a unique
style going on be thug my dog son [ __ ]
you know I got your back dog and when
you go in I'm [ __ ] holding it down for
you son by holding a Dunham you hone his
girl down no I'm gonna be nice to his
lady I'm gonna drop if you take her out
Oh get her nails done in that sit son I
stop at the nails brought a rest of the
body that's up to her and the Lord so
I'm gonna take your kids for a ride take
them to the chuck-e-cheeses you know do
different things for them are you in
there
- you thought huh you're a good dude man
well I'm being good to this dude have
you seen be thug brah I see big funny
sees a busted air force once each one of
his pant legs is a 36 okay it's just two
different people's jeans sewn together
haha definitely man
he looks like um I've heard of bootcut
I've never seen [ __ ] World Cup he
looks like Mark twizz aim bro if you
look at his outfit he's looks like he
ate Mark Twain what do you mean but he
definitely um I've been in prison call
him full rack of ribs oh yeah he seemed
like nez tall or not can we see how tall
he is chin looks pretty tall his girls
sure he's sure his girl looks like that
Brooke Hogan he's got that sugary Brooke
Hogan look uh I think I might be his
cousin danielle has submitted the photo
cousin bra then the key they're gonna
have something to explain into the
children soon that's the cousin of
family tree gots a rope swing on it you
know what I'm saying
somebody's playing in the branch don't
play hopscotch in that frame both of
them got a real kind of tit oh no yeah
both doesn't yeah they do titties yeah
beat Doug looks a little bit like
Terrence Howard if Terrence Howard think
they're white guy who might be Latino he
looks more like [ __ ] Lindsay Lohan
[ __ ] mean right he looks like the
kind of dude that they put a LoJack on
when he leaves jail who's that what's
that thing the old house arrest bracelet
I guess costly has that bracelet oh I
bet he has four of him on dude I bet he
wears my bracelets oh yeah he's got the
whole set but I bet it they put LoJack
on him when he leaves
but rest in peace man that's all I gotta
say he's not dead bro he's still
thriving he's in a graveyard have you
seen the Baha I think I have seen this
first 48 I've seen how this ends what
else we got
all right King interesting it be talking
ever just to me Doug
shut up to that t.j.maxx dressed style
yeah there's scare squad man I love that
though I love what he's got going on
there he is that kind of uh he always
says that kind of cult vibe yeah it's
kind of like loosey-goosey
yeah like Ku Klux Catholicism going on
you know and I respect I like what he's
got going on first team all yard gang
gang bro he said yeah he seemed like a
Tony Gwynn of the [ __ ] ah of the yard
yeah he's got that Cecil Fielder kind of
goes to jail but gets his act together
sort of look white guy that Lenny died
screw yeah yeah Lenny dykes I came is
dude you were so [ __ ] dyslexic I
can't even impersonate it that's the
[ __ ] great thing why let me dice how
do you say it again let me die I'd say
it like he says it Lenny Dykstra yeah
what else you got you all right King
state like he says I better get right I
shouldn't be making fun of disease yeah
it's all good man I'm sorry I have a
different stuff and I'm [ __ ] up no you
beat down syndrom well barely though and
they said you coming back you did it
that's the thing you did it but it
flares sometimes in a flare-up like when
I look at you in the Sun I'm like oh
[ __ ] here we go
you know what do you guys
[Music]
[Laughter]
I love that guy ride this shout-out to
j-rock gave Ron obviously using all of
the equipment at San Quentin State
Penitentiary I appreciate it and I
respect that a hundred percent man
you're my real deal and this is a great
question
sex robot King immersed Ingham Brendan
I'm gonna go ahead and King them because
to get good anything you gotta practice
since 10000 hours to get good at some
think if think if you were a kid think
if you're nine you just got that sex
robot in your basement yeah instead of
jacking off into socks and cushions and
[ __ ] stuffed toys you got this real
woman you just pound townn in it you
know learning learning making mistakes
but learning learners are for common up
to buy time you're 18 you're [ __ ]
mandingo you're [ __ ] the Wayne
Gretzky of dick and [ __ ] down oh dude
you just it's an educational you yeah
you're freaking just John Stockton is
just dick assistant John yeah and by
Tom's I mean blow behind the back yeah
let you be able to come behind your own
back and that's the matrix yeah yeah
that's the kind of stuff you can expect
out of have any sex robots you know but
I'm gonna say sting it because human
thing with sex robot well first of all
sometime you know you go on vacation you
leave the batteries in there the
batteries leak out you got acid leaking
out the back yet stay then you got a
dirty sex robot and thinking we got to
take that [ __ ] in at a shop you know or
that man [ __ ] and also how about this
they're gonna want to robots dude
they're gonna want
yeah it's sex for like the first couple
months then they're gonna want to cuddle
then they're gonna want to drive your
car they can turn that into a wallet
well click off you don't think they're
gonna learn if they're learning out a
[ __ ] and do all of these downward
Daniels and all of these different
positions they're gonna know how to
[ __ ] keep their own switch on you
don't think what our [ __ ] is gonna
reach back there and fix their own
switch you think yeah dude if they can
give a [ __ ] they can [ __ ] flick a
switch there dude I didn't think of it
you know you thought about terminator
but they're [ __ ] us yeah well they're
[ __ ] us for like a week and then and
they're stealing our cars dudes
buying [ __ ] with our credit cards
in there our friends [ __ ] each other
Wow and we just have to watch its The
Terminator but it's exactly the
Terminator I'm still into it cuz I think
you'd be a lute learning tool I think
the best of robots I put I think the
glass is half-full I think if you have a
robot you can dump in their mouth then
when you're 18 you're me all good
I bet rape goes down I bet everything
goes down you can take it out on the
robot
those things are powerful you can hate
[ __ ] a robot you get every Friday night
instead playing video games your friend
could run a train on a new sex robot
think about the possibilities dude
that's just you your buddy like being
gay but not one to admit it really I
think y'all are just [ __ ] if there's a
sex robot there why you're called
machine bro news Tiffany my bad if you
got that Tiffany 3000 you know yeah but
what if you got that Donna 200 and it's
a little [ __ ] sharp in there she's
older and she talks back yes feels like
wine she has recipes she rattles off a
tooth that's it and what if you just get
a refurb of like one who was like yeah
like maybe it's a robot that used to
work at be like a you know a mannequin
and like a um The Container Store but
now they refurbed it and got it doing
sex you know and it's just like stiff
and shine yeah yeah yeah yeah oh right
there who wants who want we got a sale
on know it's like the navigation it's
like the navigation on your iPhone you
can change the language that a gallon a
gallon yep you know fill it yeah sail in
the stool section you know and like what
the [ __ ] is going on here they're gonna
have some hiccups we could also
hopefully download like Debbie from the
Bronx oh yeah she's just get us fun like
oh yes [ __ ] it [ __ ] it I think your mom
was gonna get pacing around here my
quitting the hell is gonna turn it down
yeah turn it down
Oh busting this jar so I can use for
cooking Oh boss I need icing for
Cinnabon language though bro
you're disgusting look j-rod it
definitely seems you need a sex robot
though based on this guy student has all
the sex robots bro this guy personal
address is just like you and every
episode do you notice that yeah I love
him brother he's you're my brother
yeah he is my ears a robot yeah
definitely big King it kids can learn
from it and can skip you can decide what
language to go with and just bust nuts
and not hurt anybody
caring it ok and I'm gonna go sting
because I think that um the sex robots
it starts off with sex and ends up with
other stuff pay my car insurance robot
you know move out of the house robot you
know yeah it starts with sex but it just
it devolves into some really you're
talking about the plot of the Terminator
yeah thanks bro come up with your
original ideas that's the termination
yeah I am I'm talking about the plot of
Terminator is becoming your life art
imitates life brother amount Dave he
just goes by Dave what's up bring
whatever Theo gang gang gang gang got a
question for you guys
baths for males can get or sustain you
know that broad dip can we watch him
again is he in the tub he's wet he's
doing that ramen noodle well he also and
thank you for sending this in Dave yeah
and also I'm sure was it easy to film
this while you're in the tub yes we're
honest intense tattoo I've ever seen but
that's fine especially when you're on
ice and one of your organs has recently
been cut out by some people in Mexico so
I'm sure was very hard to make this you
pay the bills they give you two spleens
bro one it one is for a down payment he
woke up in a nightmare he's making a
dream and here he is now okay yeah it's
a good point in you guys now yes there
goes what makes us strong but it's gonna
be a catchy saying it's like a bad idea
if this guy's brave enough to send in a
video of him taking a bath he's
obviously basically like a low-key local
Liam Neeson type of guy yeah [ __ ] with
this dude yeah I will answer his
question what do you
Brenden mail bath dude baths in general
unless you're [ __ ] toddler big sting
it
I [ __ ] hate baths first of all you
jump in the bath yeah and all that dick
cheese and the the nut juice and your
taint juice just float in the water then
you just sitting in it like a swamp
that's like you're a gay baby it's that
it's that like you make it as human
chili its disgusting
I'm out yeah showers all day I could
burn and done you don't you don't seem
like a man that's okay with being alone
by himself for a little bit yeah yeah
right you got to do something you know
you gotta you know dig into my psyche
you know you don't want bro yeah what's
up man yeah I don't like bad dude I
couldn't imagine is laying there all
peaceful in a bathroom what would you
even do Jack why don't you light a
candle didn't think about your ancestors
and not quit thinking about yourself you
forgot the right dude you're right goon
here's what I'm gonna say to you say yes
yeah I'll take a bath every now and then
brought throw a little fish oil in there
[ __ ] just get all tilapia in there
and I know what Big Dave is talking
about relax and taking the edge off dude
being a natural man getting that bro dip
you know getting that [ __ ] eater mano
calling soap guy you know the Spanish
cat you know well she's not Spanish but
somebody is I'll tell you this man I'm
okay with the bro dips I think it's a
good thing men need to start you got to
spend time to strategize you can't just
be going constantly in a steam room ho
yeah not everybody has a steam room
brother and a bath you can take anywhere
you could dig a hole in a yard and put
some hose water in it and get in there
for a little bit if you have to in relax
good and so I'll you know like in that
mud hunka mud bath it's only mud at the
end of the beginning it's just pure
water and then your mud dog you know ha
get in there mud I'll meet a [ __ ]
kroff you a mudskipper mudskipper you're
seeing the mudskipper fish rose your
mudskipper
it's a skimmer no mudskipper is it a
real fish
hell yes officially down a menu bring it
up never seen on a menu you'd be
surprised man mudskipper
look at him broke they look like
tadpoles but with red eyes
leave them pose you guys look exactly
the same the guy's eyes are just
as far apart they'll look like it can
you get a frontal view of it and they'll
only do side photos they don't they
don't like their pictures taken straight
on oh wow they're unique fish can you
eat that as it sails do they grill it no
you don't want to you don't wanna
deep-fried a mudskipper there we go
there's somebody catching a hit a skeet
right that's there's something about
Mary but you know put it in my mouth
instead of my hair you know that's an
old-fashioned style right there
beautiful animal right there the
mudskipper thought you would like that
but I'm gonna say for the bath man you
stay in there and you stay safe dude and
look if this could have been a cry for
help video can we read between the lines
on this because to me it definitely
reeks of having somebody who's one of
their spleens has been cut out it might
be in Europe yeah yeah some sort of
shady Amsterdam business being had yeah
he might be hanging out with Teddy
Ruxpin yes a king a man good luck out
there I'm gonna say sting the [ __ ] out
of it
no human brisket but I'm gonna say get
to the what's it called in another
country where they have a place where
it's like America but it'll just a
little bitty building yeah get to the
embassy brother next one all right let's
bring up one more what do we have here
you have Michael McCrea what's up boys
Brad King bee sting buzz buzz relevant
premature Nick gang at you the King
addition Arella
get that hitter baby condoms baby he
talking about that uh wrap for your dick
because what he's talking about deal
yeah comes for posts a Vietnamese suit
and I bought a suit in Vietnam made out
of plastic we did was it nice was a
tailored it was tailored and it was
plastic as well hmm so his hit or miss
dude it was like if you were like at a
Funeral like that was just downwind from
a carwash it was [ __ ] fire yeah I
doubt it but outside of that it was uh
you know his better look better seen
than not worn I probably looked better
in the store than at natural in the
human yeah his question was condoms man
I feel like you gotta roll the dice if
the big man upstairs once you get some
dots on your dick or a drip on the front
or some kids
then that's what he wants for you it's
life lessons you want a couple rings
around your dish if you don't have STD
can't be my friend like you having a
little drip drip and then coming back
from that adversity and learning all
right I don't [ __ ] with those hoes
anymore me I'm gonna go this direction
fellows but don't but don't just start
wearing [ __ ] bumpers like you're
bowling on your dick yeah I play play
the lane take the bumpers off bless some
loads get some dots yeah get the drip
get it yeah earn a dimple right yeah bro
you know some scars like my dick looks
like a great whites nose yeah like it's
[ __ ] battered bro Wow yeah cuz I've
been through the wringer yeah man yeah
you got to get out there [ __ ] hard rug
get a dimple and you did you know what
I'm saying do something special [ __ ]
near a fire and see you know see what
the you know see if the devil's lookin
for you because there's different
opportunities out there waiting for you
I see you got on that New England
Patriots garb congratulations to your
team and I'll be in Boston to shove all
your theater and uh February 6 do you
hate the Patriots them but I will say
this dude I look like Tom Brady and
Shrek had a son but I will also say this
that um condoms are when we're condoms
invented nineteen probably 1987 I'm not
using anything it's from the 80s still
the must don't running around with a you
know a toaster that just barely works
you got a trapper keeper yeah no no I
don't have any of that [ __ ] I don't use
stuff from seventies or eighties I would
rather if you know the Lord wants us to
have a child or we you know once some
you know one of us to get a little bit
of I'm not getting aids but I'll take an
AI you feel me and uh and and I'm gonna
letting the Lord work so that's what I'm
saying condoms dude from the past bro
you know I'm saying I use this daddy
hope you know I'm saying fingers cross
yeah
pinky swear oh you're on birth control
pinky swear yeah pinkie swear dude
you're clean pinky swear
pinky swear goes a long [ __ ] ways man
yeah for me it's everything yeah and
also sometimes just use your pinky and
then just wait around and come along and
suck it if it seems like it's not aging
well just you know swear you won't go in
there which makes it up
you do this oh god yes no finger and
somebody is [ __ ] perverse dude if you
swear to me sex or don't get involved I
think I agree but here's what I'm saying
they're gonna play the game where you're
not it's you with using cons like
playing basketball not keeping score
like what do we do yeah why are we doing
this there's gonna be a winner and loser
let's both win let's bust nuts
it's dude it's just like you know they
used to say uh they had this kid in my
class dude this boy Damien and his dad
always wore a bike helmet you know and
if I see somebody in a bike helmet bro
[ __ ] them because here's what I'm saying
I would rather my father been hit by a
car and in a coma then my father been
hit by a car and okay but everybody know
he wore a bike helmet yeah I'm saying
man yeah your dad's going by in a bike
helmet bro then you're gonna end up
doing smoking crack and doing drugs yeah
so I say condoms man with Tom Brady wear
a condom doubt it son does Edelman wear
them [ __ ] no we have gang brothers are
carrying it nope all right this one is
relationship advice oh yes it's girl's
estimate at this time oh it's a lady
whoa oh it's a lady so every man is to
sign GS Ellie's but the man that I'm
with right now does he have you hostage
why you whistle doesn't make any noise
in the bedroom like literally something
not even when he comes oh he's one of
those corpse box yeah busy my baby
sobbing he'll present but it's just like
not who's that death [ __ ] cell it's
something that they're in so much habit
of there's no way to break out of it or
than she looks like a real talk can we
get him too you know
they do something like something well
she got that nose ring right there maybe
he's got that little Moana going for me
you know I'm saying we get mallanna I
know what you're saying girl
nose-ring let me said this won't you put
a little sign in your nose say speak up
maybe maybe he'll see that maybe and I
don't know if they talk how're they been
how long they've been together maybe
he's deaf so he doesn't know what's
going on oh I doubt I'd be raping him
and he has no idea oh yeah it's not a
good time for him yeah maybe hook a
little uh or put a little bell on your
nose ring and you'll hear that rattle at
least you'll get that Christmas spirit
in the room while y'all are doing sex
but also it may like what kind of dude
is the outside the sheets like you want
to freak in the bedroom and a normal
dude on the streets is he outgoing is he
talking on the streets you know signed
up for is he a Chatty Cathy bending into
that bedroom you deaf Jeff yeah and
that's your fault yeah get get a guy
who's outgoing outside the room and
inside there's both get you one that can
do both yeah I mean who are you looking
for you're looking for an order you're
looking for somebody who's [ __ ] you
trying to you know you try you looking
for Frederick Douglas are you looking
for [ __ ] Fredrick Fred Frater Douglas
he's looking for Fred now you want [ __ ]
or you want chatter you can't sometime
you can't have it all just the problem
with porno yeah porno they expect their
own be goddamn Dirk Diggler the guy's
just trying to get his nut off and
please his girl she's looking for a
play-by-play everything that he's doing
yeah you think I'm Troy Aikman you think
I'm Joe Buck or Joe [ __ ] you know what
I'm saying I ain't no play-by-play
darlin once the Joe Rogan of the [ __ ]
game dude just wants to chill and bust
nuts girl yeah listen to a book on tape
get you some of the mayor pods and
listen to everybody you know what I'm
saying this is the king of sting well I
get powned that's if you don't like what
he's putting out I'm sure we're funnier
than he is yeah baby
and look and here's the thing he sounds
like a nice guy is that quiet Ozzy or
does he not sound at all he's a busy man
I mean emphysema makes no noise and
kills millions every year is that quiet
killed on her right bro you brought that
up and here's another thing about the
man the man I'll tell you this dude I
don't make any sounds during sex man
what am I gonna say I'm already [ __ ]
let me chill out I'll get pretty dirty
do you oh yeah I do I'll do a whole lot
of moving gravel also
like oh I grew up my teeth like your
[ __ ] like I'm Peter North this
[ __ ] North the uh don't tell you
their epistle I brought up Peter North I
don't want to get you suspended yeah I
know look at Peter no like Magellan is
that like whenever I get on the airplane
they can't track your movement look at
Peter North fell really yeah oh is that
him with his mouth open no that's that
that's all I'll show you on this your
actual yeah show me a chocolate I hope
you don't tell your P oh I told you
about this guy oh wow there's my guy ok
cos he's busting up his eyes went crazy
he's like oh no dude that's that
cross-eyed bust it seemed like he's
probably you know spewing T's tails it
looks like he went deep for that serve
what's that bone marrow bust
yeah dude he's gonna come in a little
he's gonna come up light on the soup if
you test him for he said getting deep
into his own clam chowder brother
23andme right now dude but back to Moana
your man if he's quiet he's just silent
assassin is he laying the dick down
right then who cares and what is lay in
the dick damn right I mean and nobody's
really [ __ ] that good anymore let's be
honest 20:19 right you know it's like
you [ __ ] for 10 or 11 minutes and then
it's you got to get back to the address
and it's yeah yeah you single that's
right 11 minutes format the fury baby
yeah and look here's the thing is he
quiet in general you know like what does
he like what does he like outside of the
bedroom take that into account cuz she
seems like she's outgoing he might be a
little mousy yeah maybe you're the one
who's the loud one maybe you got a Speak
Up exactly deal who's [ __ ] who yeah I
feel like mo Ana's [ __ ] the mousy guy
yeah do an impersonation of him you ever
thought about that dressing up like him
while y'all are [ __ ] and you saying
stuff maybe you put a wig on him yeah
who gives a [ __ ] it's weird Moana
but you are a dime piece and you deserve
got to be loud yes sir gotta be a banker
he's trying to cash that dime you know
and I'll say this to you as well young
buckaroo
female what I'm sayin is this like a
ruse key that they have yeah what they
have dude I used to like you know I get
during sex I'm not even good at sex I'll
get nervous I used to hold my breath I
was [ __ ] faint
halfway through it completely black but
you could hold your breath for a long
time no bowel three minutes like when
you go through tunnels can you hold your
breath for a while I'll hold my breath
through the tunnel I'll go back do only
the end everybody starts breathing I'll
[ __ ] go back I dude you look like
that guy you do laps in the tunnel that
can hold your breath oh it takes very
little oxygen and operate my brain yeah
and I'll say this straight up that a lot
of solid men faint during sex because of
the join the excitement and so I'm like
one of those goats on the internet I get
going and I hold my breath and then I've
said this out
I'm just visit the Lord for a brief
visit and I'm back you know and so maybe
that's the kind of man yep
maybe value you got this beautiful
little [ __ ] time capsule this guy
could be who knows maybe we ended up in
a coma and this is practice yeah or
maybe he's reading a book in his head
while he's [ __ ] you you know like
he's busy doing work yeah like he's like
tasking maybe he's figuring out your
taxes why stone that dick down another
question I think some other details does
he have a fat dick cuz if it's small and
he's quiet then we got problem oh that's
not information that's just you being a
little bit homoerotic brother and I'll
say this this is a great time for us to
go to an audible ad maybe the guys
reading books in his head he might be
reading but or listening to Pell we
don't have all this but if we did maybe
he's listen to books on tape yeah on
that dick did I say look be supportive
whether he might be you know maybe he's
having a little mini strokes and you're
not being there for him be supportive I
say sting it what's not king or Stannis
relationship advice
okay well I'll say this I need more
facts before I throw him under the bus
but if you're looking for loud so her
name is Jen
Jenny dolma and she had messages for
both of you two she says she loves Theo
and she thinks Brendan's a cutie and she
also included her Instagram me girl good
luck getting Brennan into some sort of a
date rape charge probably I'm John come
on Brendan seemed like a great guy and
and you seem like a great girl I didn't
pass away seemed like a great guy I'm
right here girl sorry damn let it pass
away man yeah that's true
I didn't tell you I'm from the future oh
that makes sense terminator yeah from
seven months from now okay
oh wow okay let's move on all right this
is Kaylee Carson hi guys my name is
Kaylee I've been dating my boyfriend for
a little
over six months now over ten years
my boyfriend tends to get pretty jealous
of him he changes the subject anytime I
mentioned him or gets very salty
attitude [ __ ] doesn't even respond at
all what would you do in that kind of
situation I tell you go [ __ ] Larry the
accountant and leave me alone
cuz I don't have any girls who are
friends that you know I'm saying like
I'm all sat on friends if I'm hanging
out with a girl there's a reason you
know I'm saying like I'd rather hang out
with feel and laugh if there's a girl
hanging around it's not because she
makes me laugh you know I'm saying yeah
I get I mean look at ya I dunno what
you're saying this that's your scenario
and you can see why that guy is
frustrated with it though well it sounds
to me like the friend might be a
homosexual and that's what yeah we're
all gonna be homosexual when we get
older but what I'm saying right now is
this is that this man whoever this
friendly man is did it sound like do you
bring him up around your boyfriend just
to kind of get a rise out of your
boyfriend I mean what's your boyfriend
supposed to do if here's another man its
nature inside of his inside of his
amygdala to want to defend himself you
know I want to keep you away from that
man here's the other thing what's I got
to know what the friend looks like is
the friend better-looking than your
current man mm-hmm like you see a dying
piece and he's killing he's he's an
Instagram model he's [ __ ] posting
these pictures where he's shredded and
he's just ballin he's in [ __ ]
Bentley's than your man's working out
[ __ ] remax trying to sell houses and
he's all feeling sorry for himself then
you show up always hanging out with
homeboy yeah I need I need more details
from these relationship advice
you got a Pittsburgh Penguins shirt on
is it is your best friend humor yeah gir
you know I'm saying
pretty good lives in a universe so
there's no vowels yeah yes your best
friend near me yeah here's what I'm
saying to you Pittsburgh dude yinz W I
got a pink eye over there no Monongahela
once and people know that and actually
got one of my first [ __ ] ever behind
a giant eagle over there and here's what
happened Pittsburgh only city that has
all three of their sports teams have
black and gold coloring only but yellow
but yeah yeah and also users aren't gold
so there's that like in the yellow dudes
black and black and yellow black and
like us yeah that's my good don't
[ __ ] touch me pill touch mean that
hurt sorry didn't mean to call you that
well you did and also here's the thing
yes if you say don't bring this man
around that much I wouldn't bring him up
that much but also ask your boyfriend
why is he getting upset because his
girls hang out this dude all the time
was he jealous
no he's just annoying as [ __ ] get a
girlfriend where's your girlfriend
here's every girl with a bunch of
friends who are dudes I just don't get
along with girls they're so catty I'll
have time for it so I'm just hanging
with Dave Rob and Ryan they're gonna
take me down yeah one of y'all's on
xanax or something they tell me we need
more information
[Applause]
detectives bro we should be in true
detective HBO what dude it would be true
detectives question mark bro we'd never
find anything yeah we would
we spent an hour looking for your movies
what else gets in fought my arts God
we're gonna find a Sachin Davis both
blue balls then dip down yeah sure and
what was her name Kendra aunt Hannah
yeah beautiful lady miss na she would
shoes dark she's our debut she stole her
virginity on flap my off she was hot man
let's look at a couple these side piece
from the Far East sent him in check all
right this is aunt Marilyn submitted by
James steely JD oh she's the leader of
the Hells Angels oh she came through
before man she looks like Bobby the
brain Heenan if you went to summer camp
let's bring a box let's bring up Bobby
the brain Heenan I can show you how
cross out when you bust a nut dude
I would stay cross-eyed just keep
telling my buddies yeah I mean I'd stay
like that oh damn she does look like him
Oh from the WWE yeah
that's Bobby the brain Heenan she does
look like Bobby the brain oh no she also
looks like she works at [ __ ] Pawn
Stars
she look like you're exempt on stars
like he's selling pawns and people of
Elisa's - yeah I got about a 40 feet of
water back there like some goldfish look
at her them koi fish yeah she definitely
has like like Hulk Hogan like his little
like like maybe a possibly mentally
deficient sibling that he had like like
halt Hogan like some guy who could never
get his life goes like halter Hogan once
you have leather pants because she's
[ __ ] finest bananas in the kitchen bro
the kitchen looks definitely cozy and
good snack it does it looks like she
meets makes the meanest banana bread in
Chicago [ __ ] and those are old bananas
back there that's how you own she has
that fresh ass Pepsi with thousands of
your homemade macaroons in that little
weird Raynor Brown weird right there on
the counter sweet potatoes bro sweet
potatoes yeah her name's sweet potato
Halsey you from Poland this huh [ __ ]
thing sweet potatoes on the counter
dude she looks like she just dropped the
mixtape she definitely think he just
dropped a purse full of pills - as well
and she's from Chicago I see that black
black that Blackhawks hat repping it all
thanks for being there I think she's a
beautiful lady man me too she looks like
Steven Seagal security what else do you
got huh
nice woman very kind a shout-out to a
Chicago the next one is aunt Janet
submitted by Michael Holmes bro you know
goddamn well whoever picked these steel
can't be looking at this his pee oh
officer ain't gonna have this and then
he's gonna flag this [ __ ] nows dicks
filling up that means now guys know this
is gonna happen that means not Popoff
officer and I'm about to pop off and I
see these shorties like this ah
Doug she's in Florida FNZ Florida I'm
pretty sure I saw Florida on the resume
North County Florida because there's no
honk ogen in the background of these
pockets she got that Terri bow layer
going down there
I can smell [ __ ] whey protein from
here she is just full be us and up oh
yeah you could tell she's got that bone
broth in her right now so she can get
this bone marrow she doesn't look like
she misses a day of [ __ ] squats or
deadlifts
she also took six years about what size
waist does she have six inch around and
then my ass is a triple-decker yeah that
seems scary to me a little bit but she
seems really she's working out a lot and
she seemed like she also puts lotion on
her skin
yeah she's shredded almost there's a
point where girls can get to shredded am
i right deal she's at shredded cheddar
boy she's that [ __ ] grew a there
right share she's lucky she has that ass
so she would have a little bit of that
castaway nutrition going on oh yeah she
got them double Wilson's going on in her
pants brother I'll say this is that
flatter the Flat Earth those pants that
look intergalactic and then you know
Flat Earth going on over here slat
stomach that's all booty and a lot of
brothers would track this lady down
probably in follow her home flat stomach
round ass baby yeah she got the meaty
cheeks boy Reverend that is I would
invite her for every holiday that's a
whole male Sun President's Day come on
over
that's Hormel I'll dip [ __ ] crackers
and that chili you got me damn don't
think your buzzer just cuz ain't mine
know what I love doing that alright next
one is Aunt Mimi buy submitted by Lisa
White's oh wow oh damn she look like
she's going to the club she knows she
own it yeah yeah she's gonna club for
the first time in 15 years
and she's just trying to figure it out
you know and there's nothing wrong with
that
there's nothing wrong with that she
looks like she's going to [ __ ]
Graystone's in LA and she's like all
right Lee she just got broken up with
and her friends like [ __ ] him let's do
it girl and then they're all like
Graystone's on a Friday night now yeah
and that's what's happening you are very
accurate on this from man I'm gonna nude
thank you feel very very accurate man
she does have that I'm giving it a
second chance I'm getting back out there
vibe I'm do it girl yeah she's look like
yeah I mean anything could happen on
those nights too much alcohol you know
[ __ ] a busboy cry in the car end up in
the hills and your friend though guys
who you thought were actors run a train
on you yeah do it in there no not actor
Jesse smallest ensembles you know great
that dark train baby ah you know you're
slinging just driven bleach on your back
that's Chicago trib and Chicago trip
drip it ain't bleed just come baby oh my
god we knew it was and you'd have to say
I'm some now what about this what's her
name again chin she seems like she's
innocent she's a nice Mimi Aunt Mimi
either she's either going out or she's
going on like Tony Roma's you know like
it's that date night yeah it looks like
a first date it looks like something's
going on here she's a little stiff
little nervous I can say mm-hmm and she
got them red hitters on man she got them
she got those devil sneakers
yeah and him things look nice look like
she's that been through the rack really
no worker that's what I'm saying yeah
she's a mom she definitely seemed like
she probably has a couple of kids you
think I could see a kid or two I don't
know I'm a very pretty though yeah she's
a pretty lady very pretty lady and
probably you could see that she's been
doing her best she probably had drugs an
SUV she know how much got talked into
buying a rav4 but thank God she got
talked out dude thank [ __ ] you don't
[ __ ] touch me dude
she looks like she drives like a 1
Series BMW it's white or cars definitely
white she looks like she's the best aunt
in the world but goes hard in the paint
on the weekend yeah don't even party
Debbie on Mondays cuz you know she don't
recover to Tuesday's she's gonna get
kidnapped probably and something could
happen or if she doesn't take care of
herself because she's you know she's
kind of an at-risk woman it seems like
yeah the red shoes give me a should do
anything vibe oh yeah that she's
definitely she's excited about the
future but she's also nervous about
where she is she still has some court
proceedings to go to and who knows what
can happen and she hasn't really told
the kids everything that's going on yeah
[ __ ] I think her she knows she looks
like she's going through a divorce it's
not official yet yeah like they're
separated and she doesn't really want it
to be but it is where she is and you
know sometimes that's what's going on
and it's like it's just hard to deal
with what's going to show the curveball
just shows up with Terence the giant
black guy at the house and then the dads
like what the [ __ ] man yeah it's like
what we've moved on yeah like this is
how this story ends yeah so it could be
anything could happen tonight and I just
hope she stays safe out there because
there's a lot of a lot of shady men out
there and lesbian women
who want to take advantage don't forget
about them too don't count on us both
slide you know like go [ __ ] they'll
get after to now dude I've been a couple
of lesbian ladies cut my car tires one
night so I couldn't take a take a girl
home that I met god [ __ ] cost average
at the new fullest I thought you're
gonna say they cut your hair no but they
do hit me up on the DL for [ __ ] hair
tips my bad bro it's just it's just a
one honey and let the fun room in the
back yeah that's right [ __ ] what else
we got all right now it's debate club
finally I thought we've been debating
this whole time
this is from Ashley Heyman Heyburn and
Theo wanted to know if you guys would
debate what is worse kids on leashes or
dogs in strollers that looks like one of
those first one one of those Chinese
dogs it's on zanuck so they can put it
on Instagram which is should be very
illegal if you've seen those Japanese
gerbils and dogs that they're putting
them dropping them pills into and him
ludes they're getting them hopped up on
ludes so they could make you know nice
pictures of them on the internet with
their tongues out of their mouths guys
talk about this cry for help today that
the nyquil baby yeah what's that dog's
name Elizabeth Smart is not being
treated well so there's bad stuff
happening here as a dad you don't have
kids yet but you'll realize says the dad
they're not your slaves don't put them
on leashes don't put kids on leashes say
that for the [ __ ] dogs they're humans
so why would you have him on a leash you
[ __ ] animals I love how I love seeing
a kid on a leash
don't just screams I suck at parenting
well that's fine I would love to see
eight kids on a huge leash and pulling
an old man to the sleigh with a bunch of
[ __ ] gifts you know what I'm talking
about oh like slaves
yeah no bro no bro also put the dog in
the [ __ ] cart man that's supposed to
be your quote-unquote best friend yeah I
push you around the car bro we're boys
I'd do it for you why not do it for your
dog yeah that's a thing look if the kids
on a leash if he's being good take him
off the leash throw the frisbee how to
let him have some fun in the yard
bro he's not a dog a lot of these kids
are acting like little [ __ ] so a lot
of them are dogs and here's what I'm
saying about this I'm a dog a lot of
that dog is a dog it's supposed to be
your best friend you know
you know this was a kidnapping and put
it on a leash and dress him up you know
in a little fairy tale outfit or a
little fairy costume doing it for the
gram don't get the wrong reasons what I
see yeah that's not a Stockholm Syndrome
victim you're wearing just cuz you did
your sporting around because you don't
want to make real friends
a dog is a little animal that stays by
the door and have a snack and every time
you walk in pretends you won the Super
Bowl
yeah and you can't push that thing
around a goddamn cart for a few miles
yeah selfish [ __ ] well just let it
don't be a dog and find a real friend so
kids on leashes I say yes I say hell no
better parents I say put these leash
these kids up there now I did a rod
these [ __ ] bras look that type of guy
puts cashew butter on his nuts and lets
his dog lick it off what do you got just
they're saying which ones worse and the
fans agreed that 55% say kids on leashes
Wow definitely worse dogs in strollers
dogs and strollers just yells I don't
have [ __ ] going on yeah so I decide to
do this
I agree mile I gave up on my life so I'm
just gonna make this dog look neat yeah
all right this is from Nathaniel Franco
oh yeah poet huh what the [ __ ] is up
deal and Brendan you beautiful sons of
[ __ ] Sam bro all right man beautiful
eyes and you're outgoing I'm coming from
Midland Texas hi brother I got a debate
for y'all American Muscle or
choose wisely we're talking like
American bodybuilders what kind of
muscle we talk Jay Raj a little brother
look I have the same intensity don't
they
what's up [ __ ] damn bro ain't gonna
be [ __ ] dude back off the four sig
Matic [ __ ] hype T brother about back
off the [ __ ] four clover energy train
that should I give you a heart attack
dude it looks like guy your black rifle
is fully loaded it seemed like it seemed
snortin the grounds brother Thank You
Daniel for the Steve [ __ ] yeah man
his question was Oh American muscle or
foreign cars before he answers come
these talk their cars I thought you're
talking about dudes for a second we can
get to that but let's start with cars
and offset more of a car guy than you
are so let me just list off some foreign
cars for you make the decision okay so
for when you talk about luxury cars
we're talking Ferrari yes all foreign
okay Rory Lamborghini Maserati Bentley
Rolls Royce or what that's all for p.m.
w what is it G wagons those are all
foreign Porsches foreign foreign cars
though that's foreign okay so I just
gave you laying on what about Range
Rover what about that's all foreign okay
I'm just acting the cars you telling me
I know I don't know where you keep what
about them that's just the [ __ ] bus
would be like would be Camaros costly
stingrays challengers you barracudas
what about road dogs what about that are
at all yeah sure Renault over no that's
French yeah that's what about that Ford
Escort maybe had in 1984 with the
[ __ ] sticker on the back says don't
be a [ __ ] on it did that be American
policy with that hatchback son you can't
beat something with a hatchback
so I go American muscle baby if you want
something a hatchback is a great way to
meet somebody or kidnap somebody
yeah they don't really make hatchbacks
and where all the Ferrari did do one
recently I would say in the sixth in the
60s and 70s American Muscle all [ __ ]
day
currently foreign cars all got in there
you still get your vipers you get your
challengers you got your [ __ ]
Hellcats you get the demons you know oh
you got them what is little league
[ __ ] basketball team these are the
car you got the Corvette although when
you drive a convertible Corvette
yells out kind of midlife crisis yeah I
think Alan's gonna get a yellow
convertible one I could see that me too
right now he's going through it do you
think of it oh yeah well do you think
this though that America can make a
comeback with the cars or it's just too
much sold out about like now it's too
much about safety it's too much about
you know cuz it used to be you got that
metal he was in that [ __ ] stairs like
this when you was in there you [ __ ]
you know you get in with your t spaced
out and you get out with a pic yeah
it smelled like gasoline if you lit a
cigarette the whole [ __ ] thing blew
up so y'all still no car bomb yeah it
was beautiful that was it that was an
American machine you know dodge and Ford
and Chevy made some of those not you
don't see him as much like they got the
zr1 they got the Hellcat they got the
Hemis now you got your ford raptors and
you got [ __ ] z06 is a Luber I think
Oliver you gonna burn foreign or
domestic I think it depends on what
country I'm in so I would probably burn
domestic that's fair but they both have
their their highlights and I'm a Porsche
guy though but I also drive a Ford
what's up yeah so none of this makes any
sense uh was this man's problem I can
you don't have a problem but I go
American muscle one more time about
straight up American muscle although I'm
a Porsche guy and it feels just doesn't
glad to be here if you're talking about
actual muscle I would say you thought
you're talking about helium
I'd say Mexican muscle may get you a
little thing a test 200 that McDonald
you know go to Cancun or [ __ ] you
know split a bottle with your buddies
sneak it back in a shampoo bottle oh you
know it should be it should be Mexican
steroids or Russian stairs Oh
Russian stuff is good but it makes your
head Square that Mexican [ __ ] makes you
kind of kind of leaky and greasy like
statue on the back yeah and their hand
is like you know and you automatically
get a pony Tony take Mexican steroids
just get a ponytail a [ __ ] mustache
and start hair homes like it's very
strange so I'm gonna say I do import it
steroids over American for now I know
that Mexicans doing good call : Russian
stories make you Harry
oh dude yeah that makes the women angry
and you get good at hack into computers
oh yeah the fans 65% say American muscle
America to turn Trump this is Kane a
Hurlburt oh yeah what's up fellas [ __ ]
yeah dude
Kane from Indiana ken K whoa how cute is
it oh you just stole that car and the
kid was in it got a debate club for you
would you rather go the rest of your
life with your name being was pronounced
or misspelled oof Gang Gang buzz buzz
shut up - dad dad life yo take care
Theo van man Brandon Schwab feel bad I'm
gonna use that by the way
shoutout to dad life you don't know [ __ ]
about that it was it was it is small
projects confio how's your plants i have
two plants they're doing okay yeah doubt
you water them every day ever give them
attention oh I've done things to him
first of all I'm gonna say this brother
you have what his name Caine Hilbert
came in Hurlburt ya know one of the best
rural wrestling names ever paint Hobart
it's a great name it's nice to see I
love your little brother in the back of
what you know whatever son bro is this
dad life you don't know if it's dad dad
could be a stepson hashtag daddy dad's
the kid does look like him it looks like
a beautiful young man I'll say that cane
what was his question would you rather
go your life with your name misspelled
or mispronounce now let me does anyone
ever mispronounce or misspell Pheo
yeah no Steve AC writer - shut the [ __ ]
it's Steve yeah all the time
Steve come on you student homeschool
should like Steve is there Steve in
attendance now that's just mean that's
your mom [ __ ] with you but like when you
go to Starbucks is everyone
anyone ever [ __ ] up Theo farm they say
farm some time well coming from Brendan
when they say Brandon I'm so anal about
it when that steroid went up steroids
I'm at Starbucks why did steroids when
I've had Starbucks and they go we have a
cappuccino almond up for a Brandon if
I'm the only one in there I will wait it
out like there's no Brandon here there's
a Brandon who's waiting for a drink so
I'll wait till Brendan's called I'm that
guy you being an [ __ ] not about this
how hard is it how hard is it bro are
you fired up about it man think if well
if you went by Theodore oh yeah I'm
gonna [ __ ] it up all the time Theodore
Theodore oh yeah dad autumn means I
adore you
I'll say this brother here the thing
that happened is if you're at the place
and they've been in there since 4:00
a.m. [ __ ] shoveling coffees to
everybody Maurice Carlton Damien [ __ ]
Rodan's sure especially in LA people
come in with all kind of [ __ ] [ __ ]
names star Bassam and plant wallpaper
when the stalkers yeah little [ __ ]
that's every other person's name out
here it's like having the rapper's are
little something yeah a little bit
little xanax little death yeah you know
how many people kind of die before we
realize that like all of these kids are
just addicted to pills you know here's
what I'm saying is man these people what
was the question that you back on the
pills no I'm good
okay your question was have your name
mispronounced or misspelled on for the
rest of your life for the rest of your
life
misspelled for sure misspelled that's
easy mispronounce that just means they
don't respect you yeah hate us don't
know you're [ __ ] they spell me
they're just an idiot you know or they
just don't know all the letters or they
just they grew up in the digital age so
you don't need to know how to spell
really your phone correct yeah yeah
that's true do this Brit yeah
Brendan look at the British alphabet
there's no how many letters are in a
seven who even knows we got four I like
what's up that's true so I would say
misspelling is fine keys burning
mispronounces things all the time all
the time doing extremely craving 69
let's document that because that's gonna
go to court sometime
no idea 69% of the fans agree with you
so they'd rather have it pronounced
correctly to easy shut up dad though we
got that right yeah good good luck to
you mr. Halbert keep doing that daddy
life board though debate club so if you
guys want to do start in my heart
damn are we already through it yeah yeah
Wow this went fast bro yeah it goes fast
it did man
um keeps on tickin future dude how long
you think you'll be a lot of four man
ten years really mean ten years max no
yeah I'm dying early for sure
Wow yeah I know why do you want to go
dark why you think you'd be around to
your hundred yeah I could probably do
about 90 or be the ugliest old guy well
yeah you're gonna hang on to your hair
and screw up all the time to go let's
pull all the way back and I'm gonna make
sounds and I'm breathe you do when
you're old people does invite your and
they watch you to eat they watch you eat
and they put you by the [ __ ] window
how crazy it makes sounds you mean that
nine-year-old gun horrible and you gonna
have a hard on your sweats the whole
time when you're 90 maybe that creepy
grandpa oh yeah that [ __ ] ready they
call them I'm gonna tell you my nickname
is dick ready
Richard ready Teddy up skin I gotta
start my our start my heart this week
mine goes out to Chris Farley who on
Friday it was his we look at his 57th
birthday 55th birthday I want to say um
what about 1964 so I can't add but also
Ralphie may to this one go down that
road brother can someone do the math
look how bad we are have you pay
attention customer service these days
you go somewhere you give the guy 20
it's takes four minutes for him to know
how much change to get back to you
55 55 years old probably would have been
55 the
last Friday and you know just a man just
so much energy and like I think about
that guy and just you know probably a
lot of the demons he had I mean there's
some amazing stories about him out there
just doing coke and you know hanging his
boy out of like an 11th storey window is
your freedom feel [ __ ] out of the
window you know I didn't I went to the
VMAs though one time a long time ago and
I sat behind his brother and we have a
picture of him and other this past
weekend studio that was drawn by the sky
Brady Matthews and it's amazing piece of
work and his brother Kevin sent me an
email the other day and said hey I saw
that you had a drawing of my brother up
in your studio and I thought it was
really nice wow that's cool and it was
just nice innocent that have just warmed
my heart and so just to chris farley I
just think you know sometimes you have
too much talent for the world there's
just too much going on inside of you and
I mean that guy if you watch him when he
came onto Letterman to the Tonight Show
one time or to late night
it's absolutely unbelievably funny if
you go in YouTube that and we'll put
that in the links of the time when he
came out on to the Tonight Show or the
Late Show whichever was a man of talent
just as how do we have a talent and it's
how to adjust of excitement and joy and
lovable right and just so loveable so
yeah that would be my start my heart I
think and it was actually the other show
it wasn't it would be on Letterman I
know what you're talking about Chris
Farley's first Letterman interview yeah
Chin's aware schooler of all time Wolfie
why was that
but he's hard-working or at it though
yeah he's like maybe we're gonna play
now no okay no but you guys go and check
it out the first time he comes out it's
I mean the crowd you just see how much
energy and yeah he was like an ocean he
was like hideaway yeah I've just [ __ ]
charisma and talent yeah and laughter
and he just mastered it he'd absolutely
mastered it so Chris probably start my
heart uh my start my heart this week
would be a guy he's a dorm at the Comedy
Store his name's Ahmad Hasan
he's a door guy there he's opened up for
me in San Jose and he did a spot for me
at the ice house most recently but I was
talking to him when I was doing a set on
Saturday night and he goes yeah brother
this might this is my last year at the
Comedy Store he's been a door guy there
for a hot second really yes mix to
Whitney he's his dad's a NASCAR rocket
scientists
he's Indian so he's gonna be probably a
serial killer or shooter maybe we're
trying to be positive those yeah and do
no asana he's a great guy
Sean's a great dude but he I thought it
was interesting and inspiring because he
goes I gave myself the the at the end of
the year I'm gonna stop working here I'm
well [ __ ] you have another plan he goes
nope I just know that guys getting this
rut him they'll just stay here because I
want to grow and evolve as a comic I'm
still gonna spots here I'm a risk it all
and leave and try and find my own way
and I thought it was really inspiring so
shout out to him man
shout out to his son and that's true
that's it that birdbaths syndrome you
know if you put enough if you have a
notion right and say there's a bird
coming from let's say Ohio and he's
headed to the Pacific Ocean if you put a
birdbath 200 yards from the Pacific
Ocean a bird will stop there at that
birdbath and never go to the ocean so
sometimes you know you know seagull it
gets into that water
you got a sea gull it out and he's right
it seemed he said see Mikey ready to see
Gullit be a big bird he won't be that
stupid bird in the long yeah kiss no
rocks yeah they're gonna be that big
bird sipping on that sea water and
[ __ ] eating shrimp his son some
little bitch-ass [ __ ] night and gal
over there [ __ ] just milling around
and in scene there's the other thing
about ocean is right there yeah there's
other thing about a son his like he went
to University of San Diego and his dad's
a rocket scientist so he dropped down so
gonna be a comic downstairs like wow
terrible idea hmm rocket scientists dude
and is that a real rocket scientist you
think real rocket
wow talk about Flat Earth with his dad
enjoy that I like Rockets man me too
dude so shout-out to him and that's my
tug or pull my heart tug my nuts
whatever we do indeed he took my total
different I took my nuts this day was
Sheree who I'm in Ohio just kidding I
can't believe that Khloe's still
hitchhiking out there with that [ __ ]
camouflaged limb trying to come here to
[ __ ] wear our skin is costumes dude
yeah it definitely seems like that's a
crazy way to a ha just it's look like
she's like yeah it looks like she's the
Antonio Brown of tampons like she's just
catching those [ __ ]
she's K you know if she got that red
[ __ ] to Larry Fitzgerald yes TD Larry
splits Gerald I don't know if she shaves
her she's got that Randy Moss down there
but I will say this there's a you know
there's more than one way to eat a
Reese's we'll see you guys next week
[Music]